we're gonna watch from emergency austin
today the boys season three
hero gasmum announcement and top 10 wtf
predictions let's swing into action
people
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new video for the boys
season 3
top 10 wtf predictions the show runner
just did a big q a where he answered a
bunch of questions about what's going on
with season three the story lines the
new characters like jensen echoes coming
onto soldier boy even jeffrey d
morgan coming to season three as a new
character so we'll break it down if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
obviously careful for spoilers for
everything that happened during season
two if you haven't seen any of the
episodes yet
but just starting at the beginning
number 10 he confirmed that they're
going to do a version of the hero gasm
from the comics
no joke the best way i can explain
herogasm in the context of the show
without going so over the top that the
video gets demonetized
because that's how crazy it gets is that
it's basically a giant superhero
vacation
week that the supers from all over the
world go to like the worst most
debaucherous spring break
you could possibly imagine oh boy
i know what scene you're talking about
there isn't going to be a soldier boy
homeland or having sex scene um
but i will tell you this is exclusive
for you guys there will be
a hero gasm in season three
you've earned it you deserve it and
you're good thank you
hero cast thanks chris he says a couple
different things
also involving jensen acko soldier boy
character but
massive superhero sex pile doesn't even
begin to describe everything they get up
to so bring your penicillin and lots of
hand sanitizer for season three episodes
imagine that final scene of homelander
from the end of season two where he's on
top of the crisis but everywhere
way crazier i wasn't afraid they were
getting against
all superheroes doing it in public at
the same time at a vacation resort
together
clearly the show is rated r it's super
hardcore to begin with but it should go
without saying they're gonna
pull back a little bit from the comic
book version of hirogasm
number nine in that same breath when
he's talking about that he also
confirmed that they're not gonna do that
homelander soldier boy scene
what would probably be down for a lot of
things but he probably would not want to
do that
you could totally go read about it in
the comics if you want to get the [ __ ] i
was gonna say is it like
crazy from season two episode four
there's so many things we could say
about that whole story line with the
doppelganger him turning into stillwell
giving him all those glasses of milk
but the soulja boy homemander scene that
the showrunner is talking about them not
doing is closer to what homelander
almost got up to with the doppelganger
when he turned into another version of
homelanders
damn come on gentlemen during the
herogasm storyline is also a very
different version than the one that
jensen knackles is going to be playing
he won't be such a beta to homelanders
alpha chad energy
number eight the showrunner said that
when jensen apple shows up as soldier
boy he's going to have a more
contentious relationship with home later
when he comes to season three they're
changing a lot of
character from the comics soldier boy is
the boy's version of captain america
he was the american's first attempt at
creating a superhero during world war ii
around the same time that the germans in
vaught were creating stormfront
don't worry i will talk about her during
season 3 in a second too
but in the comics soldier boy was a
bumbling idiot that got all his squad
mates killed on a mission because he was
so terrible and the comic book version
of mallory who also
fought during world war ii wound up
killing him in retaliation for that
then in the present day of the comics
there's also someone called soldierboy2
who just wears the mantle and he's just
this beta male version of captain
america who runs the payback team
remember their version of marvel's
avengers stormfront also
in the comics led the payback team so
there might be some more references to
payback during season three
the version of the character that jensen
ackles is playing will be more like
homelander like they say that he was
homelander before there was a homelander
so when he shows up during season three
in the context of this well he'd be
racist more insecure about him because
he's such a celebrity
what they're doing though is they're
sort of giving him a storyline a little
bit like storm fronts so he'll be
both versions of soldier boy he'll be
the one from the past
and aspects of the one from the present
okay so just like stormfront he'll be
100 plus years old because they were
created around the same time will he be
a racist
back to world war ii number seven adding
to that they said that jensen echols
when he shows up will be one of the new
antagonists he's not the new main
villain or anything
homelander is kind of turning into the
main villain if you didn't already think
he was
technically homelander has not been the
main film thus far
butcher we're supposed to sip
up in season three and be a nice guy is
gonna be sorely disappointed
so he'll be a dirt bag just like
everyone else just like homelander
this is so good about it he says he's
one of these guys that's been around for
decades of vaught history and he was
homelander before homelander
so he's from a different era but he's
got the ego and the ambition
and it just comes across in a different
way because he's from a different time
awesome
kind of like a less racist version of
stormfront just as bad
but not racist in the way she was he's
not a nazi or anything like that
but he's still you know he's got some
bigotry you know he wasn't for civil
rights
they talked about his movies and tech
night in the comics is a combination of
iron man and batman he has his own bat
cave he doesn't have super powers but he
uses technology to make himself a
superhero
jeffrey d morgan is also a supernatural
alumni eric kripke is the former show
runner of supernatural jensen ackles
coming from super we gotta get mark
shepard in here now
yeah richards this is a bunch of
supernatural easter eggs throughout the
entire season
and the reason why i say is also because
jeffrey d
morgan if you're talking about kind of a
version of batman from the dc universe
he was thomas wayne inside the dc eu and
he was
almost a version of flashpoint batman in
the flash movie
so which just be really cool if they
could bring him on his tech night it'd
just be a fun week at that
time i agree with some of the stuff that
home later was up to this season was
messed up and twisted
tech night also has a lot of that stuff
going on too but number six like i said
stormfront will be back in burnt toast
anakin skywalker darth vader fashion the
showrunner was very clear about her not
being dead this is the clip of him
explaining that
storefront is not at all dead
uh homelanders it's my first time
hearing eric kripke
little stump front our little nazi
stealth part
is still alive and for someone who
dreamt of a master race that she's going
to be
like mutilated for a very long time
because she ages slow
so what he's saying is that oh she's
gonna be suffering
he'll because she does have super
healing but she'll be more like older
anakin skywalker
underneath darth vader sith armor living
out a very long life is this mutilated
ugly looking version of herself
number five they said that kamiko will
also talk a lot more during season three
he qualified this statement too because
a lot of people heard him say this and
thought that she'd start giving huge
lectures and speaking out loud no what
he meant was is that because she's been
teaching frenchie to speak her special
version of sign language
she's also starting to open up more to
everyone else inside the boys too like
she had that moment with butcher where
they kind of nodded each other and they
both
simultaneously realized what's going on
between homelander and storybook
just from watching them do an interview
together
doing that with the other members of the
boys being more of a team member a more
well-adjusted version of the character
instead of just being sort of the x-men
version of lady deathstrike
she and french and i are getting really
close at the end of season two but
they're not quite at the relationship
level of huey and starlight
yet but speaking of which number four
starlight and made
inside the seven with homelander
according to the show runner they won't
be calling the shots or anything like
that they're not going to secretly be
leading the seven or
making him do what they want him to do
but even though things are really tense
between them
they're going to be operating business
as usual because homelander wants to
continue to keep up this lie
vat needs the lie of the seven to
persist in order for them to continue
making money
but as you see during that ending scene
she's wearing her old uniform again that
should tell you
kind of what the dynamic is she has a
little bit more freedom now within the
seven they're not right
what they asked her to do starlight and
huey are still going to be a couple
they made that pretty clear in their
ending scene when he told her he was
leaving the boys but she was not so
starlight is also now
fully one of the boys she has butcher's
respect and she's totally on board with
their way of doing things she's
one of the seven and one of the boys but
number three a lot of you be happy about
this
black noir's backstory they did reveal
that no way
no way
at the end of season two after his big
fight with maeve but that's just them
talking about compound visas
big fight with almond joy using massive
doses of compound b
but in addition to teasing that really
cool aspect of the comics we'll also
just learn way more about what's going
on with him as a character
just like we did with some of the other
characters in the season like frenchie
getting his backstory
number two victoria newman in the secret
plot to take advantage of her new post
so i've already talked a little bit
about this
she's probably just going to slowly
pursue public office
and become a little bit more like vic
viveep in the comics who she's based on
victoria newman in the comics is a man
just called vic newman he's the former
ceo of vaude
and he's the current vice president of
the united states who winds up
becoming president after the previous
president gets killed
he doesn't have any superpowers but he
does have deep ties to vaughn so
obviously
the tv show version of victoria newman
is very different but it seems like
she's heading in that direction like
eventually she's going to use this post
running the office of superhero affairs
regulating superheroes and bought
then slowly trying to run for office and
this also goes hand in hand with the
future of this show because the show
runner said that they have
five seasons of the show planned for
those of you that were wondering
just like how kripke did for
supernatural he also made a joke saying
that i try not to play the head that far
because he said the supernatural was
only going to run for seven seasons and
look how many supernatural has gone for
now
i thought oh he was only around for five
white house running for office
later so for most of season three she'll
just be running the office of superhero
affairs
but yes i do think that she has deep
ties to vaughn and she is their plant
that they're trying to put in the white
house so that they can control the
government
but number one homelander in orion
during season three
so the big thing with homelander is that
obviously he's slowly losing his grip on
reality that was what that whole psycho
scene was about in that ending when it
zooms into his face and him on top of
the chrysler building
the one thing that's keeping him from
being a full-blown comic book villain
is his desperate need for attention he
needs the love of people that's why he
backed off when maeve threatened him
no one will ever love you again and that
was the one thing that caused him to let
up on butcher and let him go
so if they're planning a five season arc
i think it'll be season five before we
see him finally say screw it i don't
care what anybody thinks
it also that goes hand in hand with
ryan's arc then trying to plan a five
season arc out for him
will he become the super boy or the
better version of homelander that they
want him to be
and face off
and he's going to be another version of
what he was for him during season two
sort of the thing that keeps butcher on
the good path being a good person that's
neat but everyone
post all your predictions for the boys
season three and i have zero predictions
story lines season three videos as they
reveal more information
they'll be more teasers and stuff as
they start to film early next year
hopefully they get episodes out by the
end of next year but it could be early
2022 before we see episodes
i will be doing videos for the
mandalorian season 2 episodes in a
couple weeks when that starts releasing
so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those
videos when i post them and then after
the mandalorian season two the
avengers one division episodes will
start dropping on disney plus as well
so congratulations to the giveaway
winners for my last couple of big boys
videos
sean cloth and the razor hail please
email me on the about good
time for tv people good time for tv
for the boys season 3 teaser trailer and
click here for the boys season 2 episode
8 finale video
thank you so much tv has saved the
entertainment industry
during the panda hell yeah
let's talk about some of this it's funny
i just finished uh doom patrol
last night late last night i don't want
to give anything away
but you know there's speaking of the
number one thing they talked about with
herogasm
so well what's up the first superhero
show to do
and collection of sort we had a
community guideline strike very recent
so i'm trying to play it safe for like
three days
yeah community expression of physical
love yeah yes to see a
boy's style with a bunch of soups oh
that's
gonna be you know it'll be creative i
imagine you'll see a lot of
weird wacky disturbing disgusting
things on display during that sequence
i'm
very excited to see what bizarreness
they do
that will be very challenging to get up
on youtube
yeah we react to that it's going to be
so much fun jensen ackles being in the
show he's my favorite part of
supernatural
and we're only on season six right now
but he's my favorite part of the show
it's funny how with him being this
soldier boy character
how like dc is doing a peacemaker with
john cena
they're both like douchier versions of
captain america right
for this show which often seems like if
there's a specific type of comic
they they riff on or make fun of it
tends to be the dc
world that they're playing on so i'm
wondering would soldier boy
if they'll be using him more to make
some
commentary a little bit more about
marvel perhaps i can see that i mean
that's partly what i was thinking during
all those sequences
the clips being sourced from the first
captain americas especially if you have
him playing the original
soldier boy and then the updated soldier
boy see jessica's played both those
roles it got me excited because then i
was thinking well what are we gonna do
what
version of the boys are we gonna see in
you know the period like world war
ii time you know like are we gonna flash
back there and see kind of a boy-centric
look on a captain america-esque come-up
or something like that you know
they referenced the doppelganger scene
here and i did hear eric kripke
regretted not going full out
on that like having you know homeland or
have some homeland or homelander action
there and i remember we were doing the
reaction i was a little bit bummed out
they didn't go all the way there too
but i think they're gonna start going
all out in the next one i don't think
he's gonna
pull any punches this time around
and you know with stormfront uh being
this version of herself i
i feel like she won't be maybe a main
reoccurring character but i imagine that
whatever presence she has in season
three or any future seasons
getting like a weird palpatine vibe more
like she looked like anakin skywalker at
the end of episode three but i
feel like she's just becoming this like
palpatine figure
season five yeah true pull string puller
of everyone
there's something there and i like the
idea of getting to know a little bit
more about black noir
yeah i mean part of what makes him so
charming and fun
is he's a quiet character you never hear
him
yeah sometimes you hear him make some
noise like when he's crying so i i don't
know if it might detract a little bit if
in
in the context of the show to learn too
much
about black nour but i i was kind of
concerned that i might get that feeling
with doing that with butcher but that
just made him better
and i i think that would whatever they
have in mind
it's probably gonna work i mean i love
black noir i want more of his presence
around so yeah i'm very excited for what
they do there
and jeffrey dean morgan too jade
man potentially just get everyone
eventually super everyone for super
once walker's cancelled jared paddle in
there get him in there you know it's
bound to happen
that's why he took it eric kripke was
like do something that's gonna get
canceled so he can get you in for season
four oh that's gonna be so fun i didn't
even pick up on the
little detailed nuance of starlight
having her original costume back because
she was back in you know more revealing
skimpy outfit at the beginning of boys
season two there was a lot of like
commentary about that
we talked about that yet i didn't even
notice it when at the end of the season
oh yeah she's wielding some more power
it's cool that she's playing like dual
roles and it's both kind of out in the
open
yeah with the boy's edges they've made
public stuff yeah
starlight's betrayed so now yeah she
gets to walk in both worlds and now that
the boys are also
not fugitives she's it's considered
playing on both teams is a good thing
now
yeah you know at least for at least for
us that's for us you know maybe not for
some people within vaught
and you know what they're talking about
victoria newman of being a plant from
within sight of vaude
i don't know why my mind never even went
there
i thought oh she's you know the
alexander acosta cortez character so
maybe season three will do a riff on
they still can for where they seem to go
after a lot of like the political side
of alt-right
uh come on guys whoever gets that's so
stupid people get annoyed for me
something like it's the show
all right they're taking on in the
subject it's so obvious it looked like
she was embodying like the aoc
portrayal that i thought they'd be
making fun of like the the liberal side
and going after that with some real
commentary
on that agenda which they still can but
i do find it to be more intriguing if
in fact victoria newman is a plant uh
from within sai vaughn and that would
make sense because
certain people that were killed off just
like the cia
member at the beginning yeah i could
never put it together why would she do
that if she's working independently i
don't understand
i feel kind of dumb for just not
concluding to this point you know
yeah yeah well and i mean it to be fair
it's still a mystery and i do like that
idea of you have this person who is
posing as i think that could be your
liberal commentary right there because
there are
a lot of criticisms that you know the at
least the democratic party as it's
accepted in america is not that much
different from the other side at least
in terms of its interactions with
money and the abuses of power and
deception and whatnot and i feel like
through her character they could very
much
explore that especially if the ultimate
end game if the character she's based on
is to be kind of incorporated
is for her to end up in the white house
yeah yeah that's great
yeah which is a long play too you know
and i'm also thinking that with
homelander you know
going full psycho by the end of season
five like if they're doing
that much of a build up to the point
where he the
the public of the whole world really
believes him to be like the ultimate
super villain threat
that'd be really cool and i love the
idea of them having a solid conclusion
by season five
yet there's this version of me more than
supernatural that is thinking
this show often riffs on the political
climate that we're in
so as much as there's evolution and
changes in the political atmosphere i
feel like the boys could always have
material to keep evolving their show
superhero stuff keeps exciting exactly
but it's also about you know
character-driven story lines and like
this
idea with uh you know ryan being there
too
but you're looking after him i love that
approach of having
helping to ground him more into his
humanity of being a caretaker and
you know they didn't really talk much
about what the possibility is for ryan
to come in the future we'll see
we'll see anyway there's a lot of great
stuff after season one ended we were
like clamoring for season two
even though i feel like the general
generally speaking
the response is overall season one is
maybe a tad bit
better and more focused but i think
season two's finale just stuck the
landing
so strong and did it so incredibly well
that i think we're gonna be talking
about one season three coming for the
longest time
anyway guys what's your predictions for
season three leave your thoughts down
below subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell check out
our reactions to the boys
much love people